oh oh man
[Music]
Wild
hey what's going on and happy holidays
hot ones fans this is Sean Evans coming
at you from the Cozy hot ones cabin
located high in the snow tip mountains
of Midtown Manhattan for our third
annual hot ones holiday Extravaganza we
have an amazing show planned for you we
have Chile klouse who flew in from
Denmark he's going to be in the kitchen
with Esther Choy cooking something up
heat eater style we have camera guy Bill
back to host the third annual hot ones
holiday Extravaganza award show and then
we close it all out with steo taking on
the wings of death as only steo can it
is crazy as crazy as you're thinking
about it inside your head times it by
five and you're really only halfway
there and of course this is all to
benefit common threads our charity
partner an amazing organization who I'm
happy to say we've raised hundreds of
thousands of dollars for over the years
common threads is a national nonprofit
that Champions Better Health outcomes
through the power of food they do this
through providing nutrition education
cooking skills and quality food access
which they believe to be key
foundational pillars of long-term Health
together with their Partners they impact
30 National markets helping each
Community to embrace healthy cooking
healthy eating and the celebration of
cultures if you've donated in the past I
want to say thank you if you're thinking
about it this time around this is the
year you can see see a donate button
just below the video over here if you
have it in your heart if you're able to
this holiday season please consider a
donation your donation really means the
world to us here at hot ones the
families and kids involved and on that
note it's time to kick things off with
some very special guests please welcome
Amia Mia Quest and jabis come on over to
set guys welcome to the show
guys look at everyone hitting their
marks
were you guys good this year yes what
are you hoping that Santa leaves under
the tree toys toys you want toys what do
you want a hair doll a hair doll yeah
what about you um what do you call those
again the gaming station you want a PS5
yes yeah yeah okay I I do too Quest I
want a mini car that you can drive in Oh
I like that like a little for
Ferrari thanks for raising your hands
it's so formal for Christmas I want a
hoverboard you want a hoverboard yes all
right well I'm going to keep my fingers
crossed for you I wish that Santa Claus
was here today so I could tell him
personally we don't have Santa Claus
here but we do have the next best thing
and that's chili clouse who flew in all
the way from Denmark he's hitting the
kitchen with heat eater own Esther Choy
let's see what you guys are cooking up
thank you so much Sean I'm here with the
man the myth the legend chili CLA best
I'm so thrilled to be here I traveled
all the way from Denmark Scandinavia to
participate in this special Christmas uh
show to see me yeah yeah of course of
course of course so I don't know about
you but the holidays for me means family
means comfort food and comfort food for
me is cre Korean Fried Chicken have you
ever had it before I've bet chicken but
I've never had a Korean Fried Chicken no
I'm so excited yeah Korean Fried Chicken
is not your ordinary Fried Chicken I'd
say it's one of the best it's spicy and
today in your honor I'm taking my Korean
fried chicken recipe and kicking it up a
notch using techniques of Nashville hot
chicken really fun spicy recipe that all
sounds amazing but before we get started
I need to get into uh my holiday spirit
wa oh my God amazing chili Claus oh I'm
changed into my final form Santa Claus
today love it Santa Claus so festive es
I've created a little game to crank up
the heat on the recipe today you have
three stockings and in the stockings
there are some of the hottest peppers on
the planet we have a Carolina Reaver we
have a t that Scorpion and we have a
crossbreed a hybrid of something that
the crazy guy from South Carolina
smoking it had made whatever stocking
you choose we have to incorporate that
in the dishes that we're going to make
I'm a little nervous don't be nervous
okay can I pee yeah yeah I
can of course you can it's Christmas you
know what I'm going to go with the one
that matches my sweater very good choice
let's see what's
inside okay that's new to me
that is that could be the hybrid which
could be anything from Carolina reever
maybe a pepper eggs maybe Apollo only
thing I know is that smoking it is crazy
all right you ready to cook yeah I'm
ready to cook yeah okay so we have a
whole chicken that I have cut up into 10
pieces so we are going to brine the
chicken and this is what makes the
chicken super juicy wow and we brine it
in some kimchi juice yes wow and that's
the secet
secret our Korean fried chicken has a
very unique uh blend of flour so it's
regular allpurpose flour some corn
starch and then rice flour and then we
have some spices would you say that
Korean food is spices overall overall
it's definitely like very flavorful
Cuisine and yes a lot of the dishes are
quite spicy um but you know we're spicy
people Korea forever yeah see okay so
now we're going to batter the chicken
and then fry it I'm super excited of
this it's looks amazing I love this kind
of food this will fry for about 7
minutes okay we want to be pretty exact
with the timing so we'll put our timer
on for this we'll take the chicken out
and let it rest for a little bit and
then we'll do a second fry while the
oil's hot this is a technique in like
Nashville Hot Chicken yes you're
essentially toasting all of the the uh
spices and sort of infusing and making a
chili oil right M it's wonderful the
next step is making a spicy glaze with
the K Jang this is fermented red chili
paste this is the heart of like any
Korean fried chicken recipe and then
we'll add soy sauce honey some rice
vinegar minced garlic white pepper and
sugar and of course your secr
ingredients but but but the a good thing
could be to to slice it up and get bit
of of the the seeds because it's not the
seeds that are spicy you can see the
moisture there that's pure
capsizing we're just going to do the
second fry five more minutes for the
breast and then we'll leave the darker
meat in for 2 more minutes cuz it Cooks
a little longer
okay so it's been 5 minutes so we're
just going to pull the chicken but
remember that chili oil we made remember
what I like to do is we'll do a little
dip in the chili oil like so it's right
just beautiful this is Christmas this is
Christmas it's comfort food it's
something fun so one last part and the
glaze right and instead of like dipping
it because then it gets soggy what I
like to do is I like to brush on the
glaze I like to decorate and be festive
with some red and green chili peppers
there's nothing left to do but to taste
the chicken
cool what do you
think that's
spicy
beh for
[Music]
Christmas M the singing comes out you
know we got something special here I
think the the the the sweetness lower
lowering the heat it's balanc right yeah
but definitely it's got a kick and it's
actually building you like it very
not it's really
good Isa thank you for a very nice time
in your kitchen and thank you for
sharing your wonderful recipe I had to
bring you something this is st's butter
cookies and they are famous all over the
world but I made a little extra spice
between so as I do in my videos it's
your choice go want a chili or vanilla
but I mean you know I'm going to go with
the chili come
on M M delicious it's nothing compared
to Sauce oh actually it's kind of spicy
actually chili clouds thank you so much
for joining me today I think my mouth is
on fire right now everyone at home don't
forget to hit the donation button to
make a contribution to Common threads it
will mean so much to us happy holidays
back to you
Sean wow Chile CLA say Santa that's my
new favorite thing hey you guys uh you
guys want to play a
game all right so this is a holiday game
of would you rather okay so I'll ask you
a question I love this you do all right
Quest finally we hooked it in would you
rather receive one giant present or 10
smaller presents how small are the
presents going to be they're like uh the
the size of my my foot are the smaller
ones yeah I'm going with the big one the
big one okay yes I agree with Quest the
big one yeah yeah I agree with both of
them you want a big 10 smaller one 10
small ones I think I'm with you I agree
with you I want 10 small ones here's a
question for you would you rather eat a
gingerbread house or live in a
gingerbread house eat a gingerbread
house because gingerbread house are are
really small
that that is true it'd be tough to live
in one of those little gingerbread
houses you're right about that I choose
to live in a gingerbread house because I
could take sprinkles and jelly bean
showers yeah you've really you could you
showers how about this would you rather
have a rednose like Rudolph or long
green fingers like the Grinch red nose
like Rudolph because the long green
Fingers um they they would know that
you're basically like the grin yeah
right right you give yourself away with
those long green fingers I agree i'
rather have a red nose like Rudolph
because I can just put makeup on it and
noever know that's smart that's kids are
smart Quest sure I would say a red nose
because Christmas Rudolph is something
in Christmas and it's almost Christmas
makes sense to me and I feel that
Rudolph is special he is special Rudolph
is special but let's not lose sight of
the Grinch over here the Grinch is
special too you know he's just been kind
of ostracized from the community and
forced to the top of the mountain and
then you have all the town's people kind
of gossiping about him and it kind of
turns them into a monster but then what
does he do he comes down in his attempt
to ruin Christmas he actually sees the
value in it his heart grows two sizes
that day you know what I mean that's
also growth so I don't want us to just
be bashing the Grinch here even though
it would be cool to have a red nose yes
but long furry nails are weird yeah
you're right he does have weird fingers
though at the end of the day it all does
come back to that you're right here I
got one more for you guys this is a fun
game would you rather eat the hottest
pepper in the world or watch the hot
ones Awards the hot ones Awards the hot
ones Awards eat the spiciest
pepper we're not going to feed these
kids the hottest pepper in the world all
right save your comments it's not going
there okay you guys it has been so much
fun getting to know you guys happy
holidays I'll see you next year
yeah next
year I will
eat the world's hotest chick wing there
we
go thank you guys so
much good job D good job was it fun
being on TV did you have fun being on TV
yes yes and now it's time for the hot
ones holiday awards with our very own
camera guy
[Music]
Bill it's the hot ones
awards they're the spiciest the
mightiest the the hot ones
Awards we're back for your three hip hip
hipper it's the hot ones
Awards thanks Sean and friends we're
back spice Lords for the 2023 hot ones
Awards this year the hot ones Awards
committee has been crunching numbers
watching episodes rewatching episodes to
bring you the best moments of the Year
and be sure to stay tuned after for a
special Lifetime Achievement Award for
one of our most beloved guests of all
time let's get at it now I know that I
said we were going to take a look back
but this first guest took things way
back and what was one of the most
insightful moments of the Year cardi B
let the audience in on a little known
fact about her I love FDR you love FDR
yes and I love Elanor
Roosevelt and you know how he got us
through the Great
Depression with a war
mhm only president in the guy like the
four time
while he's in a wheelchair FD are you
kidding me about all that knowledge
that's so great you get an A+ for me
cardi B the award for favorite history
lesson goes to cardi B what an honor to
win a award that I thought I would never
win after high
school thank you hot on for this award I
would like to thank my history teachers
and um Elanor Roosevelt for making me
for introducing me to loving history
thank you guys so much much and I hope
to see you guys soon thank you love you
one of our favorite Awards is the award
that captures the essence of the hot
one's Gauntlet we love the unexpected
reactions of celebrities earlier this
year the bomb tried to knock this guest
out but he wasn't going down without a
fight God
damn
oh oh God
woo
woo m m LL Cool J more like LL hot mouth
J am I right Mama Said Knock You Out huh
and the award for favorite reactions
goes to LL Cool J what up what up spice
Lords hot ones Sean I want to thank you
for this award I'm still recovering baby
um but I appreciate y'all man it was a
lot of fun man one love earlier this
year we took a trip across the pond of
the UK and came back with some pretty
awesome episodes the Brits may not love
spicy food but they sure do come
prepared who could forget this moment my
tongue is
tingling and it's like as I talk more
it's getting worse yeah and it's not
going to stop for the next couple
minutes yeah we're just going to be on
this roller coaster just going to
yeah Okay good does that work yeah good
yeah when it comes to the most effective
spice fighting strategy the award goes
to a milon molenberg and her mini fan
hello everyone at hot ones I'm very
excited to accept my award for the most
effective spice fighting strategy the
mini fan was a very very big help to me
with D bomb and yeah really cooled down
my tongue it was a great time I had a
pop ones and yeah thank you so much for
the award I really appreciate it well
I'm your biggest fan Amelia
congratulations when I think back on my
favorite hot ones moment of the Year all
I can think about is when the crew was
mesmerized by a guest in the hot seat
this gu had us razzled dazzled with his
charismatic Aura and left us smiling
from ear to ear our heart sure we're
full houses that day take a look can we
get him on the
phone maybe hold on I's put this on
speaker come on hey Dad hi Dad I'm happy
you picked up you're actually on the
show right now okay I'm gonna put you on
the phone with John Stamos mic oh hi Mr
Evans it's John Stamos hi John I'm on
your show your son's show aren you proud
of him
absolutely yeah I play with the Beach
Boys you know and we're at rinia every
every other year have you seen them I've
heard you play drums with the Beach Boys
every rinia anytime we're there you have
front row seats backstage passes on me I
would love to meet you and see you after
or before the show and maybe even get on
stage and sing boban with us I'll take
you up on that okay thank you buddy take
care your son's making a lot of money by
the way
so
somebody all right love you love you
love you too all right bye that's great
that you said I love you that's so
beautiful I should call my dad John
Stamos you've won the wholesome moment
award oh hold on a second I have to uh
Mike I'll call you back okay I'll call
you I'll call you right back okay I love
you too bye hi sorry I was talking to
your dad Sean I'm so grateful uh for
this award I I was just happy to be
nominated and then to win uh most um
most wholesome moment award for for
calling your dad that day is um it just
means the world to me hold on a yes Mike
I'm no I'm I thank you that's cute no
I'm accepting this award for us actually
it's both yeah from your son all right
hold hold okay I love you too hold on
one I got to go guys uh thanks for the
award and um Sean it was I really
appreciate the introduction to your dad
we we uh we really hit it off and you
know um uh I don't know okay thanks
thank you hi Mike I'm back yeah senar
tiia John Stamos Opa last but not least
it's time for the coveted hot ones
Lifetime Achievement Award this award
goes to our first guest ever 8 years ago
he took a chance on some people asking
him to answer hot questions and eat even
hotter Wings let's take a look you know
how the show works we going to eat some
hot
food and you're going to ask me some
crazy hot questions you're going to eat
some wings with me so Cheng me I'm
challenging you what you may not know
about the moment is Tony AO went off
script and actually challenged Shawn to
eat the wings alongside him and the rest
is history congrats Mr Tony yo yes the
talking New York
Tonyo and I'm reporting from Dublin
Ireland right now and I want to thank
Sean Evans first we
Feast um in the hot wi show one of the
best shows ever created I was the first
one on the show in 2015 I just want to
thank y'all for having me on the show
and give me the opportunity to be on
there and and look what we created let's
go good job yo well there you have it
spice Lords we've left we've cried we've
shared memories and moments together and
now it's in the history books and
there's nothing left to do but get to
the Grand Finale now I know the special
is all about the kids but this next
segment is definitely not for the kids
so please please please put the
munchkins to bed and get ready for steo
not first first not second but third
time taking on the Winds of death take
it away
[Music]
Sean all right everybody it is that time
the finale of our hot ones holiday
Extravaganza and I could not be more
excited to once again be sharing a set
with steo he has a brand new special out
now called sto's bucket list a Showcase
of stun steam 2 extreme for television
the unrated special is available on
sto.com and don't forget sto's hot sauce
for your butthole and it's near perfect
five-star rating on Amazon those 6,000
plus reviewers can't be wrong steo
welcome back to hot ones that's darn
right man you do an intro like no other
wow well it's such a compliment
especially coming from you steo and
before we get started if you are able
please consider a donation to Common
threads we are very lucky to have steo
back on set to burn his face off steo
are you ready for another Go Round The
reason I'm here I'm well aware is
because I've delivered what we call holy
[__] moments many over the course of
this show yeah and I was thinking how
can I top myself uh-oh I did come up
with an idea that's so [__] absurd
I'm pretty sure it's not going to happen
but we'll get to that lat all right
you're going to surprise me here at the
end once again I'm just I'm just holding
on tight to the steo train wherever it
go that's what we do
[Music]
man
so let's get into
it nothing like super hot wings on an
empty
stomach it's a pain I know all too well
I've been there before yep it might call
for sto's butt wipes for your butthole
available at sto.com I tell you these
are the best butt wipes in the business
you know I love to see the uh steo
Empire just grow and grow and grow over
here so your latest special bucket list
is a show that pushes you to your limits
but also one that pushes the audience to
its limits with several people passing
out during the live show is that a
problem that you anticipated while
planning out the bucket list tour or is
it a phenomenon that took you by
surprise I never ever thought that that
would even be a thing the worst thing is
that a lot of the time they feel like oh
you know I need to go get some fresh air
I feel a little queasy so they'll get up
out of their seat walk out into the
lobby or the bathroom and then pass out
while they're standing and maybe hit
their head or something it was like
really really
alarming and I never wanted that to
happen but if I'm honest kind of proud
that it
did
the opening sequence with Bill bur and
the helicopter is as compelling as
anything that I've ever seen like an
action movie sequence were there any
unexpected challenges in a stunt like
that that requires so much coordination
and so many moving Parts I invested in
um a a large amount of balls of wood to
create a special billboard which we
designed and I was going to crash
through it while dangling from this rope
ladder you know from the
helicopter but the wind didn't work
fortunately uh we had electrical wires
to crash me through
instead dropping from a rope ladder
attached to a helicopter and like the
air onto the roof of M tour bus was um
utterly terrifying totally sketchy on
the topic of utterly terrifying you know
the most distressing scene for me was
when you're injected with that drug
that's supposed to paralyze you from the
waist down and then it started to creep
into your upper body which you were
warned was like a major problem is that
the most genuinely terrified you've ever
been on camera is there another event
that holds the crown big time I'm
sitting there on the ground I'm like I
can't breathe and I'm thinking I'm just
going to die on the ground in this field
like with this medical professional in
Disguise everybody's going to jail and
I'm going to be dead you know like for
me to say I'm having trouble breathing
was like very difficult I I was
legitimately having trouble breathing in
enough air to say
I'm having trouble
breathing it was the most scared I've
been maybe ever on camera well I'm happy
you made it through and happy that
you're here today are you ready to move
on here to Sauce number two I am dude
but not before I tell you that I love
you I love you right back I love you
right back
[Music]
steo the good news today only five Wings
the bad news is it's a pretty steep ramp
up oh gotcha
yeah
there's no bad news on hot ones no it's
all good news here did I tell you what
happened after my first episode of hot
ones no I don't think so I was I was
fighting it so that I could
communicate and when I left I got out of
my car having to pee went over to the
bushes you touched touched my wiener was
on fire like I was totally okay
otherwise but when I grabbed a hold of
my Wier to pee in those bushes God yeah
well there's no way that was as bad as
the next time you were on the show and
you dumped a whole bottle of hot sauce
into your eye that's true that's
true so from Santa colonoscopies to the
eggnog challenge Jackass has always
celebrated the holiday tradition what's
the gnarliest stunt that you've ever
done in the icy snow from surfing Alaska
to dry ice slip and slide to the 70ft
ski jump you have some Classics under
your belt there's extreme ice skating
yeah I remember that where you fell
through yeah fell through the ice on ice
skates wearing a tutu that was fun and
and I'm almost 50 years old can you
believe it still pushing the boundaries
I love it I'm so so grateful for this
life what made your hockey slingshot at
the Frozen dome in Syracuse New York
what made that one of the most
regrettable stunts of your life I got
this call like hey we want to bring you
on the ice and do this stunt and I
thought oh great I'm in Syracuse anyway
so they had this slingshot thing and we
did the reheal it was just so lame I was
like you know what so you knew it wasn't
going to work before it happened I knew
it was going to
be I knew it was going to be terrible so
I said the only way to make this cool is
if people fire pucks at me and even with
that it wasn't
cool yeah yeah and the worst in both
worlds because I'm getting nailed by
hockey pucks all over me hurts like hell
and getting booed getting
booed
really tasty it's going to creep up on
me a little bit
yeah I love that I'm like legitimately
really
hungry is there a difference in your
mind between the kind of laugh that you
get from a stunt and the kind of laugh
that you get from telling a joke and is
one more satisfying than the other yeah
I I think laughs are pretty
Universal and then there's like like
shrieking you know ter you know like
there's all kinds of different responses
that I like to
evoke and um some you're only going to
get from like the really crazy stunts
and then you know in this special you'll
go from 1 minute repelling down the side
of a moving van to the next minute you
know setting a world record for the
longest breath hold in a pool of
PE PE diving yeah yeah pee diving
naturally which gives you more anxiety
the dangerous stunts are the ones that
are just straight gross I'm pretty good
with gross when I when it you're
comfortable with gross yeah yeah I'm
very comfortable with gross when I when
I did the belly flop off the the big RV
into the pool of
urine I wasn't even worried about the
urine I was like actually like really
scared of the belly flop right yeah not
not too much distance in that pool of
pee there I know I remember I was having
all these terrorizing thoughts of like
oh if I if I land on a weird angle I
could like break my neck and be
paralyzed and God if I get paralyzed
doing a belly flop off an RV into a
kitty pool full of piss like that's
going to be a bummer yeah what's that
going to look like on the tombstone you
know right you know somebody asked me
today what what would I want on my
tombstone he died as he lived jumping
off RVs into pools full of
piss what I came up with is here lies
steo who lived by the motto
the body is not a temple it's a [__]
amusement park baby ride it until the
wheels fall
off well on the topic of riding until
the wheels fall off this next sauce is
to bomb Beyond Insanity one that you
know at this point being your third time
trying it
yep that's
[Music]
right remember I told you I had an idea
yeah what's your idea
if I were to lube up my
butthole with coconut
oil how would it
go getting a bottle of steo hot sauce
for your butthole into my
butthole that is this is [__] up dude
it's going to get hotter than this yeah
yeah and God damn it real after hours
hotter it sounds like like I said I I
didn't think that this would necessarily
happen yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but as I
put it out there as an idea yeah yeah I
I like the idea you know uh we don't
live in sto.com rules over here you know
what I'm saying there shoot it from the
side all right well you know let's put
that just to the side for now let's see
where this goes okay
steo you know what I have no interest
and finishing this dude yeah no no yeah
that is and it takes it back and it's
pavlovian and every time I try it it
takes me back to every moment I've tried
it and it is no fun J it's no fun I
don't blame you I know I know it's
[__] up it's [__] since the guy who
just brought the coconut oil and hot
sauce on the table that's coming from
this
[Music]
guy does your dad still advise you on
business decisions and if so what's the
best piece of business advice you've got
gotten from him and then is there
anything that you found yourself pushing
back on as you build out the steo Empire
thank you for asking that
question I've gotten my dad who's
famously a retired corporate executive
hugely successful businessman in his
career I've gotten him out of retirement
he's officially working in the capacity
of my business
manager and he's able to
compartmentalize
right kinds of things I did on my bucket
list
special he's not a fan of but he sees
the value in it and he's just like a
human calculator did you recently get a
tattoo of your favorite British snack
monster munch I
did I
did
uh-oh oh that works man that d
I don't remember being so bummed on
how hot the sauce is yeah well I think
what happens I think you guys got mad at
me because I suggested that my extra hot
sto's butthole Destroyer hot sauce might
be hotter than your guys stuff but I'm
having trouble believing that that's
true right now that's what happens you
know because yeah it comes a a Turf War
over here in the hot sauce game you know
doggy dog out here
woof yeah Jesus all right
[Music]
steo farbe it from me it's a disrespect
tradition is that really the same thing
that it's always been mhm
Jesus maybe I'm becoming a
[Laughter]
[__] there you go that's perfect
textbook all right all right I'm going
to eat this and then I'm going to lube
up my butt okay all
right Cheers Cheers
brother oh man
[Music]
wild I know I know that picture is all
yours that's pict is all yours to close
things out Ste I have a little bit of a
of a thought exercise for you okay okay
if you were to build a steo museum I'm
curious which artifact would be your
version of King tutt's mask which image
would be your Mona Lisa and then which
stunt would you canonize as your
magnumopus wow what a great question
already in the works the steo museum yep
I can't wait for the ribbon cutting on
that it's called disgrace
Land good name
and the most valuable I would say the
cheetah bikini yes classic oh man it's
starting in yeah I know
woo H okay
then there's
the the shirt that I was wearing when I
laid down in rocket engine fuel and had
my buddies light it which ended up in
skin graft surgery on 15% of my body you
got to immortalize that I recently
framed the photo that you see get snaped
at the end of The Bucket List special
where I crowd serve on the very last
audience of The Bucket List
tour and uh I I'm I signed it and marked
it one of one I love that picture all
right
steo this is a historic moment oh put
that up my
butt way
better I'd like to close out the hot
ones holiday Extravaganza with this
award for you Ste oh my god dude this is
so much better dude how this is a threee
Award right here we could even call it
the award award because you're also the
first person to win multiple holiday
Extravaganza Awards and before Oh
no I I've always said that if I ever
were to win an Oscar that I would want
to shove it up my butt as I accepted it
on stage but let's be honest I'm not
going to fit an Oscar up there never get
past the
shoulders but this I think if I leave
this up a little
bit here we go hot ones holiday
extravagant our last episode ever thank
you so much for watching if you are able
please consider a
donation
oh oh my God I I'm in oh my God how
where am I in it's the first time I'm
hostage on my own show
I'm am I I'm I'm past the neck oh my God
yeah you are I did
confirm okay can I hold
it yeah yeah versus
steo
[Music]
uh oh my God is it
stuck y all
right
man I don't know if I'm
okay but I love you I love you
too all right this is going this is
going in disgrace
land W good to see you doggy and
everything thank you anybody get a photo
of it in
there yeah he's like memory card
[Music]
wow well what a way to celebrate the
holiday season and there you have it
another hot ones holiday Extravaganza in
the books if you have donated I
personally want to say thank you if you
enjoyed the show I'd like to say please
consider a donation and from those of us
here at this show to you and your
families thank you so much for watching
we'll see you next year and happy
[Music]
holidays
oh
[Music]
the